مشهد مؤلم لفاجعه اصابت ابا فلسطينيه كان
يمني النفس بان يرى ابنيه ظافر وجواد
يشقان طريقهما نحو المستقبل واذا بهما
جثتان هامدتان اخترقتهما رصاصات اسرائيليه
تشقان الطريقه نحو المقبره مرورا بجامعه
بيرزيت حيث كان يدرسا
بدي اشوف احسن
اولادي مجودي اشوف احفادي حوالي اجمعهم
جندي مش انا ادفنهم
في بلده بيت ام شمال مدينه الخليل وخلال
حمله اعتقال نفذها الجيش الاسرائيلي ليلا
علقت مركبتان عسكريتان بين جموع المواطنين
[موسيقى]
الجنود وفتحوا النار على الفلسطينيين اللي
يقتلوا شابا ويصيب نحو عشره اخرين
بالذخيره الحيه
وبينما كان الالاف منشغلين بتشيع الضحايا
قد شاب فلسطيني مركبته باتجاه مجنده
اسرائيليه شمال مدينه رام الله اصابها
بجروح خطيره لكنه لم يتمكن من الفرار
طردته سياره شرطه اسرائيليه واطلقت النار
عليه بشكل مباشر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
و تشهد الاراضي الفلسطينيه ومحيط القدس
انتشارا مكثفا لقوات الجيش الاسرائيلي
عمليات اعتقال واسعه وبحث مكثف عن خليه
فجرت عبوات ناسفه في القدس قبل اسبوع
واختفت اثارها تماما على الجانب الرسمي
تدين السلطه الفلسطينيه هذا تصعيد
الاسرائيلي والاستخدام المفرط للذخيره
الحيه ضد المتظاهرين وترى ان ممارسات
الجنود الاسرائيليين اصبحت تتم بتشجيع
رسمي من وزراء محتملين في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده عبد الحفيظ جوعان
العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه